la neige tombée en abondance ces
derniers jours ne fait pas que des
heureux en plaine mais elle fait le
bonheur des stations de sports d'hiver
même les petites stations de basse
altitude
elles ont un taux d'enneigement
exceptionnelles et pour la plus grande
joie des touristes et des commerçants
c'est le cas en auvergne et dans les
alpes-maritimes carine azzopardi la
bourboule dans le massif central deux
mètres cinquante en haut des pistes pour
cette petite station un tel enneigement
et exceptionnel alors ici tout le monde
a le sourire
j'ai tombé vraiment au bon moment en
quantité
les conditions sont vraiment optimales
et nous avons beaucoup de demandes
actuellement depuis le début du mois
les pistes ne désemplissent pas à la
clientèle est familiale et outre le ski
de descente beaucoup choisissent la
promenade dans des endroits encore
préservée je suis clair bien agréable
beaucoup de neige beaucoup de soleil en
face à putis merveilleux du manuel
c'était très bien bilan 80 7 % des
commerçants qui vivent de la montagne
sont satisfaits d'ores et déjà ils
savent que leur saison sera très
rentable plus au sud sur les hauteurs de
nice
une autre petite station fait son beurre
d'ordinaire le public se déplace plutôt
dans les grosses stations alpines cette
année il est resté sur place pour une
journée ou un week-end les chiffres de
fréquentation exploser cette année 80 %
de chiffre d'affaires en plus par
rapport à l'an dernier
ça représente plus de 40000 forfait ski
alpin landu donc fleurir sur les
remontées mécaniques sa pensée c'est dû
en grande partie à la météo bien sûr la
neige est de très bonne qualité cette
année les deux tiers du domaine qui est
sont enneigées résultats les commerçants
se frottent les mains
30 % de chiffre d'affaires en plus neige
plage naturelle
pas de neige au canon les gens viennent
c'est super
la petite station devrait investir dans
de nouveaux télésièges et espère doubler
ces chiffres de fréquentation l'année
prochaine